This is a case about swinging dicks.
So says Judge Lawrence Van Djk of Second
Amendment fame, who did that video
discussing firearms technology. That's
right. Judge van Dijk just dissented
from a major case in the US Court of
Appeals from the Ninth Circuit that
denied an appeal by the Korean spa in
Washington State that was forced to
forced, believe it or not, to have naked
men
come into the all female spa with women
as young as 13
in attendance. You're not going to
believe this case. And Judge Van Djk
powerful to send here and the response
there too. Very exciting stuff. Crazy
stuff. Let's break it down when we come
right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of Dina, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar,
and I'm proud to say the top voice in
the Second Amendment in America. Thank
you. 2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. All
right, folks. So, this is a crazy story,
but it's true.
Judge Van Djk, Lawrence Van Djk, who you
may recall is the judge that has written
several powerful decisions involving the
Second Amendment. A lot of common sense
there, follow the law, an originalist,
right out of Harvard Law School. Judge
Van Dijk, of course, is the one that did
the video
that talked about firearms law
technology, or should I say firearms
technology, explaining how guns work,
how they don't work, and the like, in
front of his AK-47, as I recall, that's
on the wall of his chambers in court.
Well, Judge Van Djk is back in the news
again and in a good way in my view,
which is bringing attention to a series
of laws in the United States that are
forcing all female establishments to
accept males, males, even if they're
naked, into those establishments
on the grounds that to deny the males
that identify as females as females. Uh,
guess what? that violates the law. And
that was the case in Washington state.
Specifically in Washington state, they
have an anti-discrimination law that
says you cannot discriminate on the
basis of biological sex or your gender
preference. There is a Christian spa uh
known as the Olympus Spa, the Olympus
Spa in Washington State. This was a spa
that is run by Koreans. It is women
only. Women only. It is a traditional
Korean spa. I don't know much about
these but apparently uh it is typical
for the women to go to these spas to
kind of unwind to restore embrace
vitality whatever it is uh for health
and well-being. Uh but part of the
process of going through these spas to
rejuvenate uh is that they're focused on
women and only women. But part of the
process that you go through requires you
to be fully nude, fully naked for
whatever the treatments are. And this
has been going on for some time. Again,
it's a call a traditional uh Korean spa.
Well, it turns out that a man who
claimed to be a woman filed a complaint
with the Washington State Human Rights
Department, whatever it's called out
there, and Washington State's petty
tyrants went to this Korean spa and
basically cited them. basically
complained and investigated them, saying
that their policy of not allowing men
that identify as women into their all
female spa violated Washington state
law. Well, after this occurred, the
Korean spa sued the state of Washington
and made a series of arguments,
including that this violated their
Christian beliefs to let men fully naked
come in to their all female spa. Well,
this went up to the Ninth Circuit.
Needless to say, the Ninth Circuit panel
ruled against the Korean spa in favor of
Washington State. And then there was an
request to rehear the case on bon and
that's where we are now. Well, of
course, this being the US court of
appeals for the nine circuit out of San
Francisco, they sided with Washington
state overall and denied the request to
rehear this case on bonk. That prompted
the following disscent from Judge
Lawrence van Dijk who was very upset
about the denial of uh on bonk review
here. And here's what he had to say.
This is a case about swinging dicks. The
Christian owners of Olympus Spa, a
traditional Korean women-only nude spa,
understandably do not want them in their
space. Their female employees and female
clients, do not want them in their spa
either. But Washington State insists on
them, and now so does the Ninth Circuit.
You may think that swinging dicks should
not appear in a judicial opinion. You're
not wrong. But as much as you might
understandably be shocked and displeased
to merely encounter that phrase in this
opinion, I hope we can all agree that it
is far more jarring for the unsuspecting
and exposed women at Olympus Spa, some
as young as 13, to be visually assaulted
by the real thing. Sometimes it feels
like the supposed adults in the room
have collectively lost their minds. woke
regulators and complicit judges seem
entirely willing, even eager to ignore
the consequences that their Frankenstein
social experiments impose on real women
and young girls. Well, that surely got
everyone's attention, including Elon
Musk among others, for basically
starting off a descent in a case in the
US Court of Appeals for the N Circuit
with this is a case about swinging
dicks. Well, anyway, several of his
colleagues, something like 25 or 26 of
them, a whole bunch of them were very
upset by the tone and the way that Judge
Van Djk wrote the opening of his
descent. And here is in a nutshell what
they had to say about it. Check out what
the majority had to say complaining
about Judge Van Dijk's use of language.
Check it out. The American legal system
has long been regarded as a place to
resolve disputes in a dignified and
civil manner, or as Justice Okconor put
it, to disagree without being
disagreeable. It is not a place for
vulgar barroom talk. Nor is it a place
to suggest that fellow judges have
collectively lost their minds or that
they are woke judges complicit in the
scheme to harm ordinary Americans. Well,
that's why they're upset that Judge Van
Dijk says, "This is crazy that you're
going to let a familyoriented
Christian-based Korean traditional spa
that involves nudity and all women for
women by women, and you're going to let
men with their genitalia exposed to the
staff and to the customers. You're going
to allow all this to occur. and the
ninth circuit apparently doesn't see a
problem with the Washington state law
that gives rise to this outcome. Well,
needless to say, Judge Lawrence Van Djk
uh who again is a very smart guy,
solicister general, former solicitor
general of Nevada, um and also a Harvard
Law graduate among other things. He had
this to respond to his colleagues.
You're going to like it. Check it out.
Finally, I'll respond briefly to my
colleagues discomfort with how I've
written this descent. My distressed
colleagues appear to have the fidious
sensibilities of a Victorian nun when it
comes to mere unpleasant words in my
opinion yet exhibit the scruples of our
nearly departed colleague Judge
Reinhardt when it comes to the
government trampling on religious
liberties and exposing women and girls
to male genitalia. This kind of
selective outrage speaks for itself. The
public deserves a court that is actually
trustworthy. We should be earning that
trust, not demanding it like petty
tyrants. Yes, the introduction to this
descent intentionally uses in decorous
language, but that is quite literally
what this case is about. Male genitalia
is precisely and only what the spa for
religious reasons objects to admitting
into its female only space. The fact
that so many of our on our court want to
pretend this is a case um that this case
is about anything other than swinging
dicks is the very reason the shocking
language is necessary. The panel
majority uses slick legal arguments and
deflection to studiously avoid eye
contact with the actual and horrific
consequences of its erroneous opinion.
The ordinary Americans affected by the
majority's opinion do not have that
luxury. squirm as we might think, it's
only fair for our court to have a small
taste of its own medicine. I think
that's quite interesting that what Judge
Van Dyke here is he but there have been,
you got to put this into perspective.
There have been dozens of cases like
this all across America where, you know,
opinions get written upholding
government authority to force people to
interact in this way, women to deal with
naked men in bathrooms, in locker rooms,
whatever. And no one's really paid any
huge attention to it. It's kind of get
some media outrage occasionally on Fox
News, maybe, or on the internet. But now
that Judge Van Djk has really used this
language and and enforced the issue,
forced a spotlight on this issue, I
think that will make a big difference.
And by the way, here is how he basically
sums up his views uh toward his
colleagues who are upset with the
language that Judge Van Djk used in this
opinion or specifically in his descent
from the majority view that these Korean
spa folks uh don't have a claim to shut
down Washington states forcing them to
embrace naked men in their all-women
spas. Check out what Judge Van Djk has
to say essentially concluding his
remarks in his descent. Sometimes
dignified and civil words are employed
to mask a legal abomination, or to put
it in a vernacular perhaps more
palatable to my colleagues Victorian
sensibilities, quote, "In law, what plea
so tainted and corrupt, but being
seasoned with a gracious voice obscures
the show of evil."
Sometimes coarse and ugly words bear the
truth. I coarsely but respectfully
descent from our court's willingness to
leave this travesty in place. And that
quote, I believe, is from Shakespeare,
FYI. Anyway, folks, very interesting
news that Judge Van Djk has brought a
spotlight hugely onto this crazy case,
to this crazy issue. It will be very
interesting to see on the surf petition,
which I assume there will be one to the
US Supreme Court whether the court takes
this case because this is the kind of
sort of fact pattern that I do think the
Supreme Court would be interested in
where you have a a Christianbased
um all women by women for women spa
where there's nudity involved and
they're being forced by Washington State
uh run now by my former law school
classmate at NYU Bob Ferguson. Uh I
think there's a good chance the Supreme
Court might take this case because the
fact pattern is so insane and there's
very little doubt that the attention
this case is now going to get thanks to
this powerful descent by Judge Van Djk
which has now put a spotlight on this
craziness uh I think that will make a
difference because again uh when the
public notices and starts to talk about
it well that's how you get real social
change for better or for worse. All
right, there you have it, folks. Very
exciting news out of the Second
Amendment oriented Judge Van Dijk who
really understands the Constitution and
this is further proof of it. And uh
again, thanks for tuning in. Make sure
you follow me over there on X at Varbox
Dire. Don't forget to subscribe both the
YouTube and the Rumble. And I'll talk to
you again real soon here at the Varbox
Diner. Orders up. Table 2A.